In today's installment of Collab Week,
I am joined by the brilliant and breezy Louise,
also known as Sprinkleofglitter, and we'll be
collaborating through the medium of painting.
LOUSIE: I would like to paint me and
you filming a collab. CHARLIE: Okay.
LOUISE: So it'll be a collab
in a collab in a collab.
CHARLIE: Okay, I like that a lot.
I'll draw myself.
LOUISE: No, no. You should
draw me and I'll draw you.
CHARLIE: Okay, so you just stay there.
LOUISE: Okay. Oh, you're an actual artist, then.
CHARLIE: Well, just a little.
LOUISE: I would have just drawn a circle
and been like, "There's your face."
CHARLIE: So, one of your
hands on your hip.
LOUISE: Oh, yeah, yeah,
I like what you're doing there.
CHARLIE: And that's your hand.
Put a paintbrush in your hand.
LOUISE: Charlie, I can't wait for you to see
what I'm going to paint for you here.
CHARLIE: God, this is going
to take so long to paint.
LOUISE: Here's your face.
CHARLIE: Okay.
LOUISE: And your hair. There we go.
CHARLIE: Yep, that's about right.
LOUISE: Ahh! I can't draw! Okay.
CHARLIE: There you go. LOUISE: Very tall.
CHARLIE: That's lovely.
LOUISE: Done!
CHARLIE: That's the drawing bit.
What do we start with? LOUISE: Painting.
CHARLIE: Yes.
LOUISE: Okay, I've gone outside the lines.
CHARLIE: That's alright.
And the pink bits at the end.
LOUISE: I feel like I'm letting down
charlieissocoollike, the channel,
like after you've done
videos on science
and you get some pink imbecile like
painting this awful picture of you.
CHARLIE: I'm perfectly happy with it.
Anyone else who doesn't like it can deal with it.
That's some thick paint
right there. Oh, Jesus.
LOUISE: You can really get the
texture of your hair, though.
CHARLIE: My brain is leaking
or something over here.
LOUISE: Let's see, I want to
do pink for your skin.
CHARLIE: It's quite hard
to do skin, though.
LOUISE: I think this whole
project is hard, if I'm honest.
CHARLIE: Wow.
I feel bad for myself.
LOUISE: Ta da!
CHARLIE: I just noticed my mouth. Oh no!
Why did you put a piece of
poo in my mouth?
LOUISE: That's your smile.
CHARLIE: That's my smile?
LOUISE: That's your winning smile.
I've given up with the paint brushes.
Cut out the middleman,
that's what I say, Charlie.
CHARLIE: It's working for you,
clearly. Alright.
LOUISE: "Clearly." That was
a bit of sass from Charlie.
What color eyes do you have, blue or green?
CHARLIE: I have blue eyes.
LOUISE: Let's say they're green
because I've already done a lot of blue.
Let's say they're a viridian hue. This is what
like...um...what's that one that did those ones?
CHARLIE: The one that
did those ones?
LOUISE: Van Gogh, this is what
he did it like. Like textured.
CHARLIE: Like even the fact that he is a painter
and you are painting isn't necessarily
a link I want to make between
this and Van Gogh.
LOUISE: I don't think he would mind.
All art is art, isn't it. CHARLIE: I guess so.
LOUISE: Do you want to be
doing yellow shoes today?
CHARLIE: Yeah, why not?
LOUISE: It's like mustard.
CHARLIE: So it's sort of like I've got like bloody
poo in my mouth and like mustardy poo.
Fun fact: did you know that
at this point in the proceedings,
one of the cameras stopped recording
and we didn't realize? So, skip to the end.
Here we are explaining
everything we did.
TOGETHER: Ta da! CHARLIE: Okay, so now let's
explain everything that you just missed
LOUISE: So I did sort of some of
astronomy with our star and the stars.
This is Charlie being very excited
but also maybe...shot.
CHARLIE: So this is my heart just here.
LOUISE: And there's his hands and a cup of tea.
CHARLIE: I heard you say that
you were going to do tea.
LOUISE: There it is. CHARLIE: I didn't really
realize that that was what--
LOUISE: Look it's just right there.
LOUISE: And what my favorite part of
you is is your glasses and eyes.
Beautiful. If I was a painting girl,
I'd fall in love with you.
CHARLIE: This is basically exactly what you look.
I've managed to recreate you perfectly.
LOUISE: It is like looking in
the mirror. Wait, look.
And also, what you missed is we
named it "Collab Attack."
CHARLIE: I didn't actually notice this when
we were filming: I misspelled "Collab."
LOUISE: I did notice that
when we were filming,
but I didn't want to say
because I was like, "Oh, no..."
CHARLIE: Well, I'm still proud
of it. Collab Attack.
LOUISE: Me too. It's a master piece.
CHARLIE: I think we did a good job.
Yay! Collabed together. Woo!
Thank you for watching.
LOUISE: Thank you, Charlie.
That was fun. I love you. Bye!
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Lumbly-jumbly. Thank you
very much for watching,
and if you'd like to watch the other two
collaboration videos from this week,
you know what to do.
Goodbye!
SILENCE